but I really get motivated when people
tell me it'll never happen for people
that are entrepreneurs there's no cut in
the corner there's no magic bullet
there's no cheat sheet we have to take
risk if we don't take that risk I go
back to it it's the biggest risk that we
take need motivation watch a top ten of
belief nation what's up at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded on to
the world so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from growing up the
son of Cuban expatriates and having his
parents divorced when he was really
young to becoming an award-winning
rapper actor singer and record producer
he's pitbull and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite stick to
your gut but I really get motivated when
people tell me it'll never happen this
like do you know this I mean it happens
to me all the time in my business you
got understand guys I got to reinvent
myself every record that means every
three to six months I got to find myself
again because the last record or the new
record is not as big as the last record
see everybody same oil I made my going
to understand I got a guy that's sitting
in an office there hasn't been to a club
salad you and quanto sign you don't in
the local food aisle say oh I lied no
good I don't understand nothing telling
me what a hit record is stick to your
gut stick to what you believe in
understand your Worth and go okay well
this is where you build an
infrastructure at least in my business
we built our own team on one one-stop
shop where if someone says no we don't
think it is they don't worry we'll check
back in in a month and we'll see who you
know and we just happen ago Oh that'll
never work and in in a month at Depot
Genesis you know this is really starting
to sound like a hit yeah so that
motivates me that that to me is what it
makes me get up in the morning go what's
next rule number two always get better
at the end of the day this is called the
music business so you've got to continue
always find ways to better your business
it's kind of like Apple you know if he
stayed on on a laptop then what would he
be no but it would have Steve Jobs and
the whole team come up with AI Touch
iPad iPod now it's iCloud it's always
finding ways to get better and that's
the way I looked at it through music I
said well now I can just go from rapping
with everybody neighborhood to the whole
world and
and now everybody's doing it now I gotta
figure out the next movement and I gotta
figure out my next I some rule number
three work hard
well my mother growing up had every job
known to man worked I mean me personally
I went to probably about 25 different
schools lived in good neighborhoods bad
neighborhoods worse neighborhoods but my
mother sold water I was right there with
the knocking on doors my mother sold
cable I was right there knocking on
doors with her she sold Avon I was right
there knocking on doors with her and way
I mean you name it she did it I was
there with her when she would do
telemarketing and I seen how she would
pick up the phone and I started working
into the market and picking up phones
and I learned that I think that not only
to be an entrepreneur is it's thinking
outside the box that I agree with 150%
but I also think it's all about an
approach and not only an approach
physically and approach mentally because
if if you're chasing money it runs all
right if you're making money it's
different all right so for people that
are entrepreneurs there's no cut in the
corner there's no magic bullet
there's no cheat sheet it's really
simple as complex as it may sound hard
work work hard believe in yourself
they tell me all that time Chico that's
another name that I got by the way they
say Chico and you're so lucky Chico I
said man you know it's funny harder I
work lucky I get it's really that simple
and people think that we there's
something genius to the things that we
do and it's not because look in the
music business
it's just that music business and it's a
business where half of them don't know
music and half of them don't know
business have no business in music what
is this I'm confused right well guess
what we have to constantly do fight
because it's 90% business 10% talent and
I'm far from talented but our outwork
you rule number four learn from failure
I came up with a slogan and I told it to
my kids all the time I say there's no
losing only learning there's no failure
only opportunity
and there's no problems only solutions
so to me what failure is failure is the
mother of all success if it wasn't for
Michael Jordan getting cut from his
ninth grade basketball team he wouldn't
have became Michael Jordan you know if
it wasn't for I've seen an article the
other day where they were talking about
Oprah Winfrey and how she got fired
because she wasn't good for television
you know you got people like Walt Disney
who got fired if I'm not mistaken from a
newspaper saying he had no imagination
to maintain a look at the toy you seen
these are the same people that I got a
deal with Tommy was worn out what's not
a hit record so what do you tell them
you tell them you know you know that
that all they can do is learn and come
back bigger better stronger because all
its gonna do is lead you in the right
direction see if you're always winning
and you don't really understand what it
is the win you gotta take those losses
you gotta take those hits there's got to
be the valleys the peaks to UPS the
Downs in order for you to when it does
happen you go WOW Eagle no this is what
it's all about and not only that it's
never about making you guys it's always
about maintaining it that's the toughest
part rule number five break the barriers
I said that when you were younger you
ran into some trouble for being a
blue-eyed cuban-american I always tell
me why light-skinned cuban-american from
that from Miami anything was Miami
wasn't respected in no way shape or form
when it came to the hip-hop industry at
a certain time it was just to live and
that was it was she had to have crew you
had a trick daddy Trini a trick he
opened a lot of doors
Luke opened a lot of doors as far as
fighting in the Supreme Court for the
First Amendment being one of the first
bands a ban in USA first African
Americans to go platinum they
independently and have his own pressing
plant and so to me he was the blueprint
of the independent mind state which I
still use to this day so for me it was
four strikes against me trying to get in
the game you know cuz when I went on
tour with Luke and I did you know
Mississippi Alabama Arkansas South
Carolina North Carolina you know and
you're going into these deep parts where
they look at you who is this guy you
know yeah
that's cool where white guy no no Cuban
Cuban was killed you know so I learned a
lot from that and I think they learned a
lot from me also and at the same time it
taught me how to break barriers knock
down walls but always through music rule
number six take risks when I visit
students also tell them that the
greatest risks they take is not taking
one which by the way miss Martinez
taught me that and I use it to this day
any time I feel that should i I feel
nervous like I feel right now
hey I take the risk and for all the
students for all the teachers and
followed educators here we have to take
risk if we don't take that risk I go
back to it it's the biggest risk that we
take rule number seven enjoy the journey
we're living in a society that's filled
with instant gratification instant
instant instant gratification but if
they only know the more you want things
faster okay and they come fast because
we used to say it about drug money in
the streets what comes quickly leaves
quickl because it's easy money you don't
appreciate it you don't understand it so
to me it's not about building a business
and making all this money yes don't get
me wrong there's no hidden agenda here
guys we all want to generate I get that
part but man the priceless part is the
journey the priceless part is all the
knows you run into all the failures that
happen all the slip-ups you know all the
times you got knocked down that is the
fun part of the story that's why when
you get in a circle of people and you're
talking to them about success and you're
talking them about what it's really like
they respect you and they love to be
around you because you admit what it
took to get there you know and that to
me is a true entrepreneur a true fighter
someone that goes you knock me down
which I'll get back up all its gonna be
someone's fun you know and that those
are the things that that I look forward
to rule number eight collaborate how
does it help you to be
a featured artist on an album and to
actually have other people in their name
to your project well I mean for one it's
it's a marketing staff from a marketing
standpoint obviously it's it's something
where you're tapping into numerous
audiences you know working with so many
different people working with Enrique
Iglesias you're gonna tap into a certain
audience Marc Anthony another audience
Jennifer Lopez Shakira then the great
thing is about the music and the the
position that we're in were able to tap
dance between different genres and
different cultures then you got records
with t-pain records with me know he was
saying Kelly Rowland and Chris Brown and
these are all things and I think over
the years not only have we gained the
respect from from them you know I also
respect everything that they do but I
also understand that growing up in a
city like Miami has helped me a lot to
understand music from so many different
perspectives because it's a melting pot
right right you know so I growing a lot
growing up around so many different
people allow me and to think out of the
box when it came to music and from a
marketing standpoint I mean what better
than to be able to be that bridge that
ambassador of being able to bring music
this way and music that way and be able
to really show literally how powerful
music is rule number nine reinvest in
yourself the most important thing that
any artist can do is real simple Oh be a
Taliban Kido will be other agents that
can tell you they can get you this house
or this car at is tenant or bearded US
you get that money and you reinvest in
yourself because no one's gonna bring
you back a return on your money more
than yourself meaning your career so if
you get a record and you invest into
yourself the promo or the record the PR
on the record the video on the record
and you put a team behind it it may cost
you a little bit but you just doing what
the label is gonna do for you or
supposedly do for you when you do that
for yourself it's the best investment
and rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip week what do
you say to someone who to help them
follow their dreams advice don't sleep
you know no bottom line I mean they call
it dreaming because you're sleeping
while this happens you know I've lived
my dream every day I wake up I go out
there I work hard for it patience
passion perseverance equals success
everybody you know you call it a dream
no no no you can make it reality so I
always say you know I dream and they
stay dormant they stay sleeping you know
so for everybody out there it's a dream
but wait up and get out there and get it
and then a lot of people they just think
this is easy and it's it's it's far from
that but you gotta love it anything that
you do you got to love it you got to be
passionate about it
now I've got two very special bonus
clips from pitbull that I think you're
going to enjoy on how to have a long
term vision but before that my question
today for you is what is your favorite
pitbull song of all time the greatest
pitbull song ever leaving the comments
below I'm really curious to find out
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clip
it's hard for me to say yeah I'm
successful yes this is success mmm thank
God that we've reached a certain level
but I don't want to plateau by by saying
that I would say I get that I can I
think there's so much more to do I get
it
and and we have another thing in Spanish
Passos Cordoba Talladega which is short
steps your own vision you know and
that's the way I feel about everything
that we got going on and success Dahlia
is just like let's go Dolly's also you
can hit like Donna doodle you know
what's that mean I mean hit it hard the
baseball of baseball that was my my
volleyball game right now hitting it
hard
so when you say it because it is your
motto what do you want people to think
when you say dull a that is all about
energy there's like we're about to go
into some energy so usually when you
hear it is right right before I go into
the hook all right when I'm finishing
I'm like the most important work ever if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]